[Music]
hey
look we're doing another cooking show
[Laughter]
so let's see who's here who's here
oh man i don't have my chat going oh no
i don't know why it's not working
it's working on my end okay hold on let
me do it again oh you messed it up you
messed it up
i'm sure you're yeah okay okay you got
you got it
it's not working for some reason [ __ ]
i'm not getting my chat
i wonder why you know what's weird i
think it was deborah the other day
what what this isn't today's show this
is yesterday's show
[Laughter]
well that explains okay hold on
[Laughter]
there we are there you go i was gonna
say yeah because i was gonna say deborah
said something
about uh not getting being able to get
to the chat even though i was just kind
of like well i don't know what happened
all right oh now pookie throws the door
open
she was in here before sitting on my
other laptop i had to turn it off
because she kept like yeah
she's probably sitting on it like that
in a minute i don't know it's daytime
she's not going anywhere all right
so today's show is going to be about the
mother sauces
if you want to look if you want to learn
how to cook the first thing you have to
do
is uh you have to understand the french
system where the french system came from
and you have to understand the mother
sauces and then the daughter sauces that
come from the mother sauces or
small sauces yeah
now um
back in the day back in the honky
motherland
prior to the 1800s there was no real
european way
system of cooking it was just basically
you cooked some meat and you made some
bread
maybe you made some kind of gravy um
everybody's was a little bit different
it was probably pretty dry
not much spices or it was heavily spiced
uh beyond absurdity a lot of things
weren't mixed together
um there was no system to it
okay the french were the ones that got
together and damn made a system
to codify what cooking is
a good analogy would be
dudes could make noises and make sounds
but it took the french and it was really
three main players to really write the
system to make music
and be like that the difference between
making noise
and making music yeah okay that is a
very good analogy
now the main players and i always get
their names
[ __ ] up because they're these damn
frog names oh my goodness
there were three main ones i'm gonna
tell them all right three main ones was
uh
marie karem marie carame was his name
all right that was one of them and then
there was jules
uh gaufe and then there was
agusti agusti escoffier okay
now these guys all realized that
i guess you could say the center of the
french cooking system
should be sauces all right
and each one came up with primary sauces
called
mother sauces and they all had different
numbers
like some of some of them came up i
think i think uh caramel first came up
with uh
four and then i think esco iscofi
escoffier
i think came up with like seven but over
time you know some of them were so
similar and some of the other [ __ ] was
left out
over time by the time the early 1900s
rolled around
pretty much people in the in the cooking
scene
agreed that there were five five mother
sauces
and from those sauces other sauces came
now you might ask yourself well why the
[ __ ] are sauces why are sauces the
center of cooking
well before the system they were cut
they noticed that
when you cooked meat other things were
produced from that process
that you really shouldn't waste so
like pan drippings okay what do you do
with that or you boil
chicken okay you're boiling chicken then
you're doing it in water well what do
you do with the water that's stock
okay well you want some kind of gravy or
some kind of sauce to go along with this
stuff
you should be saving stock and what they
boil what they what they
realized and this is just i think it
just came from experience they kept
doing it
it was like part of their habits and
they noticed that these habits were
central in making food
and that was you took some kind of a
stock or some kind of pan dripping
you mixed it with some kind of a flour
and some kind of a butter or some kind
of an oil
so what you did was you took oil or
butter
and mixed it with flour and cooked it
and you made what was called a roux
there was a couple different kind of
roux a white roux
or a brow roo and then you mixed it with
some kind of a pan dripping or something
something that you boiled chicken in
in other words some kind of stock okay
and from those you could make these five
five
sauces all right and these five sauces
if you had them they're pretty boring
everybody's had them but if you have
them um
just like on their own they're like real
boring but those are the ones that all
the [ __ ] fancy sauces known as the
daughter sauce has come from
i'm gonna read them off to you they'll
all sound very familiar
the first one is bakamal sauce all right
and it's that's that white
creamy sauce all right and alls it is is
roux
with milk in it okay
the other one is called espanol sauce
which is
it's brown sauce based on the brown
stock
uh in other words stuff that comes out
of the meat you open bones
all right and uh also
uh bacon
you can do with that and tomato and then
you can just
bacon also bacon drippings and you just
mix that with roux
so it's like your basic brown
gravy really it's like a gravy brown
gravy
third one is tomato sauce all right
which is basically the same thing
you take you take baked tomatoes
or roasted tomatoes along with onions
and carrots and garlic
okay and you puree that and then you
take butter
and flour and make a roux and then you
add the
pureed vegetables to that and then you
got
tomato sauce all right and then there's
something called velote sauce which
means velvety sauce
and it's a clear sauce that's kind of
velvety
it's just um some kind of real clear
stock like beef stock or uh it could be
pork
it could be veal okay and then you
thicken it a little bit with roux okay
and then the fifth one is uh hollandaise
sauce
hollandaise is just a warm emulsion of
egg yolk
melted butter and lemon juice
and from hollandaise sauce comes other
sauces like
bernays sauce which is almost kind of
more like a condiment
all right so getting off into sauces
is a long and complicated process
in terms of like didn't see like
it's impossible for me to teach you
about sauces all right
there are master sauciers that spend
their whole [ __ ] lives learning about
sauces all the daughter sauces and just
sauce specialists working in these huge
restaurants making a hundred thousand
dollars
there's not many of them but they do
exist um
so i'm pointing these daughter sauces
out
and the excuse me the mother sauces and
the daughter sauce is out
so you guys can do your own research and
to know that
if you're gonna cook and doesn't we're
not about just making food
cook you have to understand the french
system that starts with these sauces and
the daughter sauces that come with them
because every time you cook a piece of
meat there's going to be stuff left
over that's going to be used in some
kind of stock to make some kind of a
sauce sometimes
and so nothing's wasted okay
and everything everything you make
produces opportunities to make something
else
you see before this system was kind of
worked out it was kind of hammered out
by cooks these are like the cooks of
kings and the kings of cooks
too but they they hammered this system
out
kind of like in the way certain guys
hammered out alchemy
or chemistry every time you did some
kind of a job it produced
renderings that could be used for other
jobs and they had to organize that in
some way
and they did a pretty good job but it is
not
totally complete like here's an example
in those sausage i just gave you there's
no condiments like
ketchup or mayonnaise or mustard are
those sauces
yeah they kind of are yeah all right i
would argue
right but that's but those are going to
be in another category they're going to
call them things like condiments
all right another thing is what about
salad dressings that's a sauce right
yeah well that's not in this system
this this is more like the from the
french perspective as i guess you could
say
the the mother sauces are more like the
mother gravies
yeah because i kind of feel like when
you get into salad dressings and
condiments those are usually meant to be
served kind of as a dip or cold yeah you
know what i mean you know what i mean
so tend to be hot yeah whereas like
gravies are more kind of like
some that'll go over meat or something
like that now
when i was working on the gulf coast
when i was in between wars
um i was at a work at a really good
restaurant and i was
i'm not uh an educated did not go to
culinary school but i studied under guys
that did all right
and in that one i guess you could say i
was a saucier i made
salad dressings barbecue sauce all the
condiments i made
ketchup i made a barbecue sauce made
uh mayonnaise um
uh prepared mustard
when you have tasting that [ __ ]
store-bought
it's okay but it just does not compare
to like the real thing like
handmade ketchup it's just um [ __ ]
believable the same thing with handmade
once you make ketchup you have what you
need to make barbecue sauce so it's all
part of the same system
you know what i mean there's a system to
those sauces too
salad dressings handmade salad dressings
that just
store-bought [ __ ] just doesn't compare
uh off the top of my head
handmade blue cheese dressing is just
absolutely fantastic
handmade um balsamic vinaigrettes
where it's been blended together where
it's not oil and vinegar the oil and
vinegar have been blended into one where
it stays mixed
and does not separate god that [ __ ] was
so good
just so don't shy away
from making sauces understanding the
mother sauces and practicing
don't shy away from making things like
salad dressings
and condiments you only you set up
you only do it for a day you know what i
mean you make a bunch of sauces it'll
last you all month
you know make a bunch of salad dressings
put them in jars that's why
i don't throw any jars away i probably
frustrate jenny because
i just saved a big-ass pickle jar i know
i got that in the dishwasher
when i'm like oh there's another one
what's that for
well i have a bunch of dried indian doll
which is like
yellow split peas i'm gonna put that in
there that way
i don't once i open it i said it's a big
bag i don't have a loose bag of that
[ __ ]
yeah it's better inside the jar so it's
the same thing you know you can get big
nice jars if it's got a nice top on it
and i go oh man that
that would be good for you know to make
you know
like i wanna one of the containers i
have is nothing but just olive oil
well actually it started off as almost
totally filled with red chili
powder red red chili flakes and i just
poured a bunch of
olive oil in there and it just kind of
turns into a real
quick middle eastern or greek style
hot oil you can put on things like kiwi
and [ __ ] like that
or on top of uh hummus
you know pour it on top of hummus
whatever hell yeah so
but save everything yeah but really i
think this is probably
about as deep as i can get into the
mother sauces without this being like a
four hour [ __ ] show
it's just for you new home cooks
this this is where you start learning
all right
well actually that's not really true you
start you start by
learning how to clean things food
handling food you know what i mean
[ __ ] proper sanitation in the kitchen
and then knife skills how to cut things
yeah i kind of feel like that kind of
stuff you have to learn like
before first first thing is food
sanitation and [ __ ]
knife skills and tool skills uh to where
you're comfortable dealing with hot
pants
like they've got some people that don't
know that cleaning a cold pan is real
hard just [ __ ] get that pan real hot
on the stove and cleaning a hot pan just
wipe it out
yeah that's sitting there scrubbing i
mean sometimes you have problems but
there's
there's ways to you know cream of tartar
or get burned stuff out of the bottom of
a pan
and cleaning a hot pan is much easier
than cleaning a
cold pan so after you use a pan for
cooking and you pour this
you pour the serving out while it's
still hot just grab a
clean towel and just wipe that pad out
wipe the back of it
you know that way you're not fighting
that [ __ ] later on once it
cools cools off and sets up and it gets
all crusty
in there yeah louis says mexicans only
have one sauce hot sauce yeah
no you they got waka sauce too
yeah there's a lot there yeah the
sausages lots of mexican sauce
it's really interesting because like i
said i don't cook a lot but
i remember um you know one of the mother
sauces being tomato sauce which
obviously is the basis for any kind of
pasta sauce or pizza sauce or whatever
among other things i always found tomato
sauce
making your own tomato sauce i always
found it really really
[ __ ] and hard to get right it always
seemed like it was not
i could never get the balance exactly
right of like between the acid
yeah and the sweet and the you know what
i mean it's like it's just always like
it always went too far in one direction
and i was like ah [ __ ] i [ __ ] it up
you know what i mean
well they're harder than they seem yeah
a recipe just written down as a general
guideline
but then after it after it's kind of
cooked down and reduced a little bit you
have to taste it
yeah and when you're talking about that
italian zesty tag
that an italian tomato sauce has
it's it's the interplay between the
balance of salt and sugar
yeah so you have to be able to detect
it's too salty
or it's too sweet one of the two so you
either etched a little bit of sugar or
you had a little bit of salt
until it's correct and what will happen
is is the two
will the salt the sweet and saltiness
eventually will will align with one
another and you'll
it'll be like this resonance you'll
taste it kind of go
wang that's it right there
that's it there's something that you're
waiting for i can't describe it
well i feel like it's slightly different
for each person because some people like
those thoughts a little bit sweeter some
people like a little bit salty because i
like a little bit sweeter
it's it's based on perception yeah
probably but everybody has that point
where you get into it and you're just
like ah there we go yeah you have to
find what's going to make you and most
other people happy
you know what i mean but it should be
everybody should be pretty close to the
same page
yeah you know um and
yeah a lot of people forget stuff like
they don't put any kind of beef stock in
it that's one thing
now it doesn't have to but beef stock
will help it
all right or bullion cubes which is you
know same thing
yeah in this case and uh red wine
a lot of people will forget to put that
in an italian
tomato sauce and then another thing that
really sets it off is of course like
depending on how much it is like a whole
bunch of parmesan cheese
yeah and that goes in there too
but it starts off as this mother sauce
basically
the the in the french system it kind of
starts with that
after this french system is kind of
implemented
european food back in the honky
motherland got
got a lot better now you know
wars interfered with certain things and
the
russia kind of fell to communism and
they were [ __ ] starving to death they
didn't really have good
tastes and things and not everybody
could get
things you know what i mean reliably you
know during the world war the area
eras but um here in the united states it
was like the land of plenty in
comparison
so a lot of the stuff that was kind of
offshoots of the french system really
thrived over here
and there was a lot of wealthy customers
here too
so yeah friends france is the
is the capital of the cooking but the
capital where all the money was being
made was over here
yeah the united states had a huge market
well i mean
even even gordon ramsay went to went to
cooking school in france
yeah so he knows all about yeah and
really
america america made gordon ramsay the
multi-millionaire that he is
yeah i suppose so i mean he has a lot of
shows over there as well but
yeah but all the money was i guess
because it kind of took off i guess he
took off over here i guess because he
was kind of mean
because people like that but he was he's
more mean on the american show than the
british show
he's not mean he's just i mean you know
what i mean you know he's not mean
he's just he just that's the kind of
leadership i had when i was in the
kitchen
that is old school yeah you know um but
that's the way it's supposed to be done
if not you just won't have any order in
there i mean cooks are [ __ ] maniacs
real cooks yeah the maniac
the scene when i was in was probably not
the way it is now
that we really did cook um or at least i
worked for places where you know there
were other places they didn't cook they
just got some [ __ ] from cisco and heated
that [ __ ] up in the microwave [ __ ]
yeah put a pre-made sauce on it set it
out you know i was like
yeah corporate very very corporate
there's a lot of that
the corporate deal is punching a clock
not very artistic it's the same thing
over and over again it's not your food
it's somebody else's food really
it's not your menu that you're executing
so
it doesn't matter who's cooking it there
isn't any kind of
artistic flair to it it's corporate fast
food you know yeah
it's the same [ __ ] um but
some guys will do that because just
because they have to you know they're
getting a paycheck
sure you know i mean you know you do
what you got to do but the kind of
city the scene that i was in you know in
the 80s and the 90s
man the guys that worked and
guys that worked in the kitchen you know
they all had their own hierarchy you
know between the chefs the line cooks
the prep cooks
the guys that were doing [ __ ]
pastries and desserts and all that kind
of
it was there was a whole hierarchy there
and it was kind of like a
almost kind of like the rock stars of
the of the [ __ ] working
world because there was this [ __ ] going
on between
cooks and waitresses and what was
happening outside
work there was a lot of that they were
all going to the strip clubs together
there was usually there's a lot of wild
partying and drugs and [ __ ] involved
too you know yep um it's it was kind of
like
kind of like the music and club industry
yeah it's interesting that there's so
much overlap it's very very similar
yeah we'd be [ __ ] jamming all the
[ __ ] badass music listening to
ramstein and stuff
you know and it was if you especially if
you have a young chef
which i like to work for with for young
good
chefs you know like the guy that i
worked for was younger than me
yeah a good three years you know but he
was a [ __ ] badass
chef he was like he was like he was like
a gordon ramsay type dude fear real
fierce
him and his buddy in there and he was
having guys from europe that he went to
school with come in
and and and intern with him for a while
you know i had a guy from germany
interning in there
uh we were because it was
louisiana-style
cuisine but but he had changed it a lot
he had one of the best barbecue sauces
i'd ever had
and it was a uh it was a bourbon-based
jack daniel's [ __ ] barbecue sauce
that he made from scratch it was [ __ ]
great
really good one of the best um another
one of that
you know i made it but it was his recipe
yeah you know
um another one that he had me making was
a uh
it was a white chocolate
pudding what do you call it a white
chocolate bread pudding
with this sucking whiskey
glazed gravy not great whiskey sauce on
it
it was [ __ ] great really good brown
sugar
brown sugar whiskey sauce we need to
figure out how to make that
i forgot it's been so long we could
probably find it on the internet
you see another thing is that you don't
have this [ __ ] memorized i mean every
day i was executing that may after
three days three days of my whole
[ __ ] work week
was just salad dressings um
salad dressings and then condiments like
making
bar making barbecue sauces making
ketchup making mayonnaise
um you know so to make mayonnaise you
had to hard boiled all these eggs
and then you had to separate the yolks
from the you know the yolks from the
whites
and you couldn't waste all those yolks
so there was other stuff that we were
doing i don't forgot what we did with
that yeah
nothing was [ __ ] wasted yolks i'm
trying to think yeah nothing was wasted
and uh we used it for in other things
and then uh so it's like three days out
of the week it was nothing but just
making
sauces and condiments all day
and you can't remember all those recipes
and salad dressings
so he he had all his recipes in this
damn binder
that he had to lock up at the end of the
day we were closing down we locked all
that [ __ ] up
he didn't want any of that [ __ ] leaving
because those were his recipes yeah
and he gave you so much to do you can't
really remember it
yeah and probably i mean after a while
you would just kind of it again
without yeah not anything about it to
get the book out and go this and that
this and that and all the pre-measuring
and it ended up making the stuff by the
gallons yeah
like five gallons of [ __ ] blue cheese
dressing
you know in one gallon containers at a
time
you know and sometimes you'd say give me
two of those that's 10 gallons for that
week you know
if some big event was happening that's
pretty awesome though because i feel
like not a lot of places would make
as you know a lot of places would make
their own dressings and stuff but i feel
like a lot of
restaurants even kind of fancier ones i
don't know if they would go the
whole hog and make their own ketchup and
mayo that dude was sucking
that dude was um
i had a super super high standards i was
going to say anal retentive he was super
super high standards
if he didn't make it it wasn't coming
out of the damn restaurant
but that's good that's admirable he
considered it to be an insult
yeah so why would i pay i can make that
and
he said he made everything or had us
make it but he knew the recipes
that's pretty awesome actually he was
real good at math
like um he could take a recipe
that was written to only yield like
maybe like a gallon
or you know or not a gallon but maybe
like [ __ ] a quart
and go and scale all that up in his head
to make a five five-gallon batch
yeah without doing much thinking
you know so yeah he was pretty good with
the math just doing it
in his head either he was visualizing it
that yeah i've heard that a lot of
people that are real good at math like
that that's kind of like that
visualizing proportions yeah yeah yeah i
think that's how they and it would come
up it would come out perfect
and you go yeah that's good yeah but uh
yeah
yeah so working working under him as a
as an apprentice
that's where i understood the power of
gravy's
sauces and condiments it just elevates
everything
yeah it seems like if you know if you
think about it it seems like not that
big a deal oh it's just the sauce that's
over the main thing
but it makes a massive mess there's
nothing like a really good
grilled hamburger with the right bun and
good quality lettuce with a [ __ ] good
tomato and good onion on it right
but with real homemade really good
cooked
ketchup yeah yeah with
real mayonnaise you know you made
yeah it's just it is a totally different
experience well like i said if you
if you buy stuff off the shelf you know
in the territory store
yeah yeah well they have to like i said
they have to put you know things in it
to keep it from going bad
like spoiling you know so they have all
these kind of additives in there
and if you're making it at home you
don't have to put all that stuff in
there yeah it's not going to last as
long you got to use it up quicker
but it tastes a lot better yeah so i
will say like in our um
in the cookbook like we have a little
thing called like condiment corner
and pretty much any time there's a dish
that has a condiment or a sauce or
something like that we have like a
little thing that says how to make it so
we have
a thing about um we have three or four
different salad dressings i think
there's like a couple barbecue sauce
recipes in there
and then we have like stuff you you make
your own peanut butter you make your own
grape jelly make it out apple butter
you can make um you know ketchup mayo
mustard
all that kind of stuff like you know so
so we just have a
you know duck sauce thai chili sauce all
that kind of [ __ ]
so we have like recipes had for adam
make all that stuff
cause i mean mainly i mean you know a
lot of times if we're just like having a
burger or something like that yeah we
just like buy [ __ ]
ketchup and mayonnaise mayonnaise and
fans but
it is like much much better when you
make it from scratch i don't think i've
ever made ketchup from scratch i've made
mayo from scratch and i've made grape
jelly from scratch
and i think i made peanut butter from
scratch before it was just started off
with tomato puree
yeah you know get it in the big cans had
to put it in a gigantic pot
and it was just sugar and some other
stuff i forgot everything that was in it
and then you had to cook it yeah yeah
just like cooking like cooking tomato
sauce but you have to cook it down the
right
consistency and it's just the flavor is
[ __ ] outstanding a lot better than
heinz or hunts
yeah oh yeah you can control it too
and it blends with other things a lot
better
because i don't know it just does i like
a good curry ketchup
yeah you could do that too yeah i had
that in um
i don't know if it's still there but
there used to be a place in new york
called
uh what the [ __ ] is it called palm frite
yeah and that all they sold was
this big cones of twice cooked yeah
like french fries essentially like
potatoes and then they had like
40 million different sauces that you
could get and they had a
curry ketchup that was out of this world
i was making this
making must something out of mustard one
time making mustard
i forgot exactly what i was doing and he
was uh back there
preparing something i'm trying to
remember what his name was
it's been so long since i've even talked
about that guy
only worked for about a year and a half
there but i'm trying to remember what
his name was
well anyway uh i said you know
i said what so what how the hell do you
make that chinese mustard
it says i was trying to make that the
other day i um i
i bought some of those egg rolls
pre-made egg rolls at
[ __ ] uh walmart you got this
why don't you just make that yourself
get the wonton wrapper and just put the
damn
yeah but what mustard is that because
what do you mean what mustard is that
as i was trying to make that chinese
mustard bad i was i cooked that [ __ ]
down i put horseradish in it
he starts laughing what the [ __ ] you
talking about talking about the chinese
mustard he's laughing
yeah he takes a ramekin
and just bags a couple bits because he
had all the spices right there you know
bang a couple things of dry mustard then
add a little bit of water mixed in
because there's your [ __ ] mustard
call me an [ __ ] and [ __ ] right there
and he goes he's laughing at me you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah just watering us yeah just water
yeah that's all it did yeah
i was [ __ ] into this god damn i
thought it was i thought it had
horseradish in it he's like no
[ __ ] no i can see how you would think
that but yeah you know you had that real
pungent
yeah yeah i didn't realize it was just
dry mustard with water yep
and i mean you know called me an [ __ ]
but we did that kind of [ __ ] you know
what i mean you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
well you know i'll get stupid
[Laughter]
well i kind of feel like well duck sauce
is hard is more difficult right because
it's also easy well i mean that has like
pureed
no no what am i thinking of
duck sauce duck sauce is nothing more
well there's a bunch of different ways
you can do that
yeah i thought it was like the easiest
way to do it
is you take uh apricot
preserves that's what i yeah that's what
i thought and you put a little bit of
brown sugar in it and a little bit of
soy sauce and heat it up
and then just stir it and let it let it
recondense
okay that's the easiest way to do it
yeah i didn't realize that that
was uh that's preserved yeah that's all
it is
uh there's another way to do it uh i
think it was done with uh
oh [ __ ] you can do it with plums i think
too yeah
yeah or mixed fruit oh yeah the thing is
those those chinese restaurants are
basically fast food restaurants yeah and
everything is made out of the cheapest
thing that they could get at the time
and usually apricot preserves is the
cheapest this is yeah
i'm saying if you're making it at home
you can make it with other things you
can make
i make it at home though i kind of want
it like a cheap chinese restaurant
though
yeah i kind of i kind of like that duck
sauce it's in the
little packets it's kind of good that's
what stuff right there
but i like it yeah but uh
they also kind of have the mother sauces
too and that kind of cooking but really
all it is is a damn
squeezed squeeze bottle of uh
cornstarch with a bunch of water in it
and that's their main thickening agent
and they'll throw that down into a wok
and then they'll throw a little bit of
soy sauce maybe garlic and ginger
garlic ginger paste or garlic ginger
paste
in there and toss it and that's
basically the sauce and miter might not
have black chip
black pepper or red pepper it's the
variations of the same theme over and
over again
or you know like you throw the
thickening agent in there or
actually you do something like
throw um some pineapple juice in there
uh squeeze some ketchup in there and
then put the thickening agent
a little bit of soy sauce and there's
your sweet and sour that's all it is
yeah it's meant to go real fast real
fast real cheap
i mean when we talk about mother sauces
that's generally like european cooking
you're talking about asian cooking they
have their whole other they have they
have
they have a whole other thing going on
over there these are just basically
it's french yeah i mean it started out
in french but a lot but
like i said it's any anything that's you
know european american anything like
that that's kind of like where a lot of
the sauces come from just from those
five
bases i was you know most of the sauces
that you see in those types of cuisine
are variations of those five
um you know like i said whether it's
tomato or holidays or whatever
you learn the five mother sauces and
then the daughter sauces that come from
them and you'll be able to pretty much
you'll be able to pretty much handle uh
any home cooking in terms of western
stuff that that that's the the same the
basic
system um they got guys that spent their
[ __ ] whole careers working
with mother sauces and daughter sauces
and then granddaughter sauces and all
kinds of
their own variations of it like i said
second cousin twice
yeah they got sauces named after old
[ __ ]
french dukes poodles and [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
some yeah you know what i mean [ __ ]
some
bavarian [ __ ] archduke's [ __ ]
girlfriend's sauce he named it after her
[Laughter]
i would love it if somebody like random
french duke's poodle dog
yeah yeah it's like it doesn't it
doesn't contain any actual poodle don't
be alone no no
yeah got one out there it's like that
name named after dude named after his
name is poodle after it
what was it what was it i don't remember
i just some dude mentioned it
that someone were named after like some
french duke's dog his poodle
you know [ __ ] [ __ ] like that so we
have to we're gonna have to invent a
sauce and call it pookie sauce yeah
pooka sauce
yeah oracle said uh i make my own cajun
seasoning for similar reasons once you
find something you like man life's too
short to eat bad food yeah it is i mean
sometimes you just want to
stuff something in your face because
you're hungry and i want to think about
it but
i don't know i just i kind of feel like
the older i get
you just kind of like if you're gonna
you're gonna do it if you're gonna do it
if you're gonna eat the calories
yeah you might as well like enjoy the
hell out of it don't waste those [ __ ]
calories
and here is the funny thing eating well
and eating real good quality
[ __ ] like this that we're talking about
it actually ends up being cheaper
in the long run it does yeah just buy
bigs go down to sam's get the big spice
bottles and get yourself
all stocked up with everything you need
all the little components and then on
after that you just buy the food items
like a piece of meat
and the [ __ ] potatoes and then you
have already have everything at the
house to make the dish
you know make sure you get cream make
sure you get milk
make sure you get you know what i mean
stuff like that yeah it's always like
flour salt sugar
as long as you have like regular [ __ ]
like that and all the spices
because we have like a huge you know
yeah we have a big thing with all the
spices in there
big cans of tomato puree yeah you little
cans of tomato paste
you want you want all that get it by the
case yeah and then like you can make of
just a
mind-boggling array yeah over a long
period of time get a big old thing of
damn bullion cubes
uh get a big thing of [ __ ] chicken
bouillon beef and chicken bouillon yeah
we have both um
you know yeah yeah just you know
components like that you can make so
much [ __ ] out of it
like you said then all you need to do is
get like the fresh stuff yeah you know
the meat and the vegetables or whatever
and then make something out of it
tammy was like pookie sauce lol contains
no actual pookies no
[Laughter]
oh my goodness i know a little pokey
all right so do you have anything else
you would like to add about sauces
okay this was actually a good idea to do
uh because i was asking him i was like
what do you want to do the food show
about
right this morning and he came up with
it the french system starts with these
sauces
learn to make these sauces and
understand what comes from them and then
that you will actually start cooking
instead of just making [ __ ] to eat
yeah yeah just starting on your cooking
journey
right david june says i can't watch this
when y'all i'm starving already and i'm
at work
just swinging by to say hi i know it's
like these make everybody hungry
all right so we'll uh kind of call it a
day
for this show tomorrow i'm not sure if
we're gonna we'll either do another food
one or we'll do a movie depending on
what we decide
later on whether we see a movie we like
or whatever but hey yeah thanks
everybody for
dropping by listening to us talk about
food and we'll see you guys
again tomorrow bye